Вітаю вас дорогі колеги
радий всіх бачити
починаємо наш вебінари починаємо його з
найважливішого не знаю як вам А мені
сьогодні цілий день зранку в голові
пісня Вечірнє сонце на слова Ліни
Костенко вечірня сонце дякую за день І
от щоб цей день відбувся хочеться в
першу чергу подякувати тим хто тримає
наше небо хто дає виспатись тому
Слава силам протиповітряної оборони
Слава збройним силам України і слава
Україні
Сьогодні ми з вами зібрались
продовжувати тиждень професійної освіти
Мене звуть Олексій Ситник і я хочу вас
познайомити із тим що власне буде
сьогодні відбуватися значить колегам я
розширює кран
значить сьогодні Сьогодні ми з вами
розглянемо новий нові інструменти для
цифрові інструменти інструменти для
професійної освіти і так
почнемо почне наш вебінар Анна Бондар
Вона розкаже про новинки на нашій
платформі професійного світу онлайн
потім Артем Коваль
покаже посібники які вони розробили в
рамках проекту і у фоскілс для змішаного
навчання та дуальної форми професійної
освіти Після цього ми побачимо
мобільність застосунок є Профі від пана
Андрія і завіти тоді Тетяна Чернецька
розповість про те як правильно
організувати гендерний аудит до закладах
професійної освіти і завершимо
знову ж таки платформою
нові курси на платформі професійного
світу онлайн і
мобільні застосунки з доданою реальністю
Але для того щоб це все відбулося
Спочатку я хочу надати слово
пані Ірині Шумик генеральний директор -
це директорату професійної освіти Прошу
пані Ірино
Добрий день шановні колеги Добрий день
шановні глядачі сьогоднішнього ефіру ми
дійсно продовжуємо тиждень
професійно-технічної освіти триває І
сьогодні ми присвячуємо наш робочий день
бо він робочий саме викладачам
викладачам професійно-технічної освіти і
будемо знайомити їх з новинками які
пропонує Міністерство освіти науки які
пропонують наші колеги для удосконалення
освітнього процесу і наш сьогоднішній
вебінар власне буде присвячений новим
освітнім інструментам на тому числі
цифровим бо ви розумієте що
ситуація в нас така після ковіту і
повномасштабного вторинню майже 50%
учнів і викладачів в системі
професійно-технічної освіти працюють
онлайн і саме тому ми зосереджуємо свою
увагу на тому щоб підтримати їх в їхніх
прагненнях дійсно надавати якісну
професійну освіту і я сподіваюся що
сьогоднішній вебінар буде для вас
надзвичайно цікавим Дякую нашим
міжнародним партнерам які давно і довго
нас підтримують розвитку
професійно-технічної освіти і сподіваюся
що нові інструменти які сьогодні буде
презентовано вони вже є в доступі для
наших колег для колег освітян викладачів
і для наших здобувачів У світі освіти
учнів вони стануть у нагоді і вже
незважаючи на те що начебто Навчальний
рік закінчується не будуть
використовуватись активно як під час
канікул так і зокрема з нового
навчального року чому кажу під час
канікул тому що наша платформа зокрема
про яку буде говорити Аня вона пропонує
і низку на таких цікавих курсів які не
пов'язані з професіями але допоможуть
розвинути ваші Soft Skills тому передаю
слово Олексію нашому модератору І вважаю
всім сьогодні плідної роботи
ну власне як було Да дякую пані ринок
власне як було оголошено пані Анну
Flower is yours
Доброго дня шановні колеги рада бути
присутня На сьогоднішньому заході Вітаю
вас із таким визначним тижнем в році
тижне професійної освіти дуже приємно
долучитися Отже я хочу вам презентувати
нашу платформу професійна освіта онлайн
розказати саме
яка ситуація зараз у нас на платформі і
показати вам і напрацювання які вдалося
нам зробити і розмістити на платформі за
півроку зараз я розширю наший екран
солов'їні та
так так так так
як видно Олексію
прекрасно видно все добре прекрасно
видно Я рада отже
власне дуже непроста ситуація склалася
враховуючи сучасні обставини
які викликані викликані були різними
подіями в першу чергу це ситуація
складна із ковідом далі із
повномасштабним вторгненням на території
України
наших небрадніх сусідів
призвела до того що
потрібно було швидко діяти і забезпечити
освітній процес можливостями для
функціонування і власне в рамках цього
було прийнято рішення про створення
такої платформи дистанційного навчання
як професійна освіта онлайн власне З
якою метою була створена в першу чергу
це було підтримати учнів закладів
професійної освіти
можливість здобувати знання і
покращувати свої навички також
підтримати педагогічних працівників які
прагнули підвищувати і прагну
підвищувати свою кваліфікацію і
розвивати свій професіоналізм також
підтримувати професійних педагогічних
працівників додатковими сучасним
сучасним навчальним контентом і звичайно
надати можливість всім бажаючим
користувачам здобувати нові корисні
знання для загального всебічного
розвитку
власне 23 грудня 2023 року на Facebook
сторінці
Міністерства освіти відбулася
презентація платформи для освітян та
партнерів з розвитку
наша презентацію переглянуло більше 10
тисяч глядачів ми починали з того що на
платформі професійна освіта онлайн було
розміщено всього 18 модулів освітніх
матеріалів для 12 професій 4
онлайн-курси для розвитку ключових
компетентностей і дві інтерактивних гри
що ми маємо зараз сьогодні на платформі
професійна освіта онлайн у нас
розміщується 24 категорії ці категорії
являють собою професії кваліфікації в
яких розміщено 67 онлайн курсів для
таких галузей як будівництво сфера
обслуговування металообробка
деревообробка агросфера енергетика
енергоефективність транспорту Також у
нас на платформі розміщується категорія
ключових компетентностей
де власне знаходяться різні освітні
матеріали які покликані розвивати
м'які навички різні ключові
компетентності також на платформі у нас
є категорія для педагогів та керівників
закладів професійного
професійно-технічної освіти
детальніше ми поговоримо про це трошки
згодом І власне Також у нас зараз на
платформі є 15 курсів розроблених
нашими педагогами
зараз трішки статистики отже як я вже
сказала що 23 грудня 22-го року ми
презентували платформу професійного
світу онлайн і за ці півроку інтерес до
нашого ресурсу
неабияк зростає за останній місяць понад
4 тисячі відвідувачів відвідало нашу
платформу професійна освіта онлайн аби
ознайомитися з нашими освітніми
матеріалами які там розташовані
знаходяться
понад 2-400 тисяч користувачів
зареєстрованих у нас зараз на платформі
і мають можливість
користуватися тими освітніми матеріалами
які там знаходяться ми постійно
промотуємо платформу весь час публікуємо
різні
дописи в соціальних мережах в різних
пабліках
[музика]
а також постійно намагаємося проводити
таку
просвітницьку роботу і останній такий
захід який ми провели власне був вебінар
про базові навички Для успішного
віддаленого навчання на якому було
присутньо більше 300 учасників Також
ми організували та провели навчання для
педагогів які навчилися створювати
навчальні курси вертикулейд storyline
якщо ми побачимо на піктограмці то ми
бачимо по областях яка активність
користувачів у нас на платформі звичайно
хотілось би щоб активність була більшою
але ми до того Ідемо і я думаю що все що
у нас попереду
далі
на платформі професійна освіта онлайн у
нас розміщена категорія для педагогів та
керівників закладів
професійно-професійно-технічної освіти
тут знаходиться 5 освітніх матеріалів
серед яких практикум з розвитком яких
навичок з собою виявляє кейс для
педагога має в собі великий перелік
різних практичних вправ які можна
використовувати педагогу при роботі із
учнями для розвитку їхніх м'яких навичок
які ти так важливі сьогодні далі
знаходиться Також у нас онлайн-курс
створення освітніх онлайн-продуктів цей
онлайн-кус буде корисним для всіх хто
активно впроваджує цифрові технології
навчання тому що тут розказується як
власне створити онлайн урок і проводити
навчання із аудиторією
також в цій категорії розміщується видно
курс
про нього ми поговоримо детальніше
згодом далі знаходиться у нас також тут
онлайн-курс гендерний аудит в закладах
професійно-професійної технічної освіти
про нього вам також розкаже наший спікер
Тетяна Яка сьогодні тут присутня І
власне також така особливість
цієї категорії то що тут розміщений
також онлайн-курс який був розроблений
нашими педагогами Після навчання
який називається розширення цифрового
потенціалу закладу освіти інструментами
селфі
Прошу всіх педагогів які сьогодні
присутні у нас на презентації заходити
до нас реєструватися на платформу
Заходите в категорію для педагогів та
керівників закладів ПТУ і вивчати
користуватися цими освітніми ресурсами
які знаходяться тут як впевнена що це
буде дуже корисно для вас і для вашої
професійної діяльності
Отже видно курс видно курс - це перший
відеокурс який розташовується у нас на
платформі власне він
він
заслуговує Скажімо так особливої уваги
оскільки пані Ірина
підкреслила те що Навчальний рік
закінчується Але для того щоб
набрати діток для вступу набрати дітей
на навчання у ваші заклади потрібно
власне провести зараз гарно вступну
кампанію І от Саме цей видно курс який
знаходиться у нас на платформі в
категорії для педагогічних працівників
за керівників закладів
професійно-професійно-технічної освіти
він покликаний для того щоб покращити
комунікацію закладів
професійно-професійно-технічних осіб
освіти також видно курс навчить будувати
репутацію закладу і бути більш прива
чином для майбутніх учнів тобто цей
онлайн-курс покликаний саме для того щоб
навчити заклади професійної освіти
правильно себе демонструвати показувати
свої сильні сторони не боятися заявляти
про себе бути готовим відповідати на
запитання і не боятися приймати виклики
от Власне цей ресурс онлайн-курс видно
курс який у нас розташований на
платформі буде дуже корисним оскільки
зараз іде вступна кампанія і ще не пізно
можливо покращити якісь певні свої
[музика]
певні свої презентації для того щоб
повністю забезпечити набір учнів у вашій
навчальні заклади
як я уже попередньо говорила ми
турбуємося про те щоб цифрові навички
були активно розвинені у наших педагогів
і саме з такою метою в березні було
організоване навчання
яке проходило в дистанційному форматі
для педагогічних працівників саме з
метою забезпечення рівно рівні зростання
фахової компетентності
які очікуваний результат цього навчання
та те що
наші педагоги які прийшли навчання Так
розширили покращили свої цифрові навички
що розробили онлайн-курси саме 15
онлайн-курсів уже знаходиться у нас на
платформі
варто зазначити що неабиякий був інтерес
до цього навчання адже ми отримали
більше тисячі заявок від педагогів які
бажали
взяти участь Але після відбору всього 40
учасників взяли участь у навчанні і
власне 15 учасників отримали можливість
розмістити свої напрацювання освітні
матеріали на платформі дистанційного
навчання професійна освіта онлайн
хочу сказати що ці авторські курси
розміщені у нас по категоріях відповідно
тих професій згідно яких розроблялися
освітні матеріали педагогами але я вас
запевняю що ви їх не сплутаєте ви їх
помітите оскільки вони мають особливе
маркування авторський курс тому будь
ласка заходьте знайомтеся
знайомтеся із розробленими освітніми
матеріалами ваших колег вчиться і
чесно кажучи використовуйте у своїй
професійній діяльності
Дуже завдячуємо усім хто був причетний
до створення цієї платформи
дистанційного навчання професійного
освіти онлайн яку ініціював Міністерство
освіти України
і власне які наші партнери які
долучилися до наповнення платформи
а саме це міжнародна організація праці
яка долучилася також до розроблення
освітніх матеріалів в рамках сучасних
освітніх тенденцій та вимог Серед таких
два онлайн-курси і дві інтерактивні гри
також партнери програми є у зв'язків з
кращі навички для сучасної України Такі
як jz саме з їхньою допомогою було
розроблено 25 комплектів освітніх
матеріалів для 10 професій вони всі
розміщені на платформі професійної
освіти онлайн також фонд міжнародної
солідарності Польщі польський компонент
програми
з їхньою допомогою і сприянням було
розроблено та адаптовано 17 професійних
онлайн-курсів які розміщені на платформі
та 13 онлайн-курсів професійної
англійської
за професійним спрямуванням також є за
програмою for Skills
компонент фінський компонент за їхнім
сприянням було розроблено 20
короткострокових онлайн-курсів та
онлайн-тренінг для керівників закладів
професійної освіти який називається
Сучасні підходи до управління закладом
професійно-технічної освіти в умовах
інтеграції в європейській освітній
простір ці освітні матеріали будуть
розміщені на платформі професійна освіта
онлайн трошки згодом І власне кажучи
пілотування уже цих освітніх матеріалів
пройшли пройшло дуже вдало ми побачили
таку надмірну активність користувачів
які реєструвалися проходили навчання і
власними впевнені що і така сама
активність буде для цих освітніх
матеріалів цих і у нас на платформі
також хочеться подякувати едап
швейцарська фундація технічного
співробітництва з розвитку сільського
контакт який для нас розробив адаптував
онлайн-курс труби арматура для професії
монтажник санітарно-технічних систем та
устаткування на підході у нас ще три
онлайн-курси які скоро будуть розміщені
на платформі в категорії за професією
монтажник санітарно-технічних систем і
устаткування
отже
яка головна мета Зараз перед нами стоїть
Ми намагаємося аби контент який
знаходиться у нас на платформі
професійна освіта онлайн
був якісним сучасним максимально
насичений різними інтерактивностями
тренажерами симуляторами віртуальної та
доданою реальністю
скажемо так уже зараз у нас є такі
онлайн-курси які в своєму
своєму змісті мають
додаткову реальність про це розкажуть
наші партнери трошки згодом дочекайтеся
І власне Ми дуже дуже хочемо щоб це був
якісний україномовний контент
далі ми також
будемо розширювати функцію функціонал
платформи саме шляхом створення
автономних курсів із
сертифікацією також створення довідників
додаткової системи пошуку матеріалів
дотичних до тієї чи іншої професії
компетенції чи навичок і головний меседж
який ми
імплементуємо
під час своєї діяльності зв'язаної з
платформою професійної освіти онлайн це
забезпечити потреби саме в напрямку Лайф
long Learning навчання протягом всього
життя
це є наші такі
скажемо так пріоритети на найближчий час
і ми дуже активно працюємо в цьому
напрямку аби розвивати і покращувати
функціональність нашої платформи
професійна освіта онлайн
[музика]
отакий от коротенький спіч коротенька
презентація я вам дякую всім за увагу і
ми не прощаємося Ми кажемо до зустрічі
на платформі професійна освіта онлайн
доєднуйтеся реєструйтеся користуйтеся
освітніми матеріалами які уже є у нас на
платформі і
рухаємося далі
Дякуємо дуже гарно
я як це дивлюся грижусь презентацію
екрану Та виключи будь ласка вот
насправді велику кількість роботи дійсно
було зроблено за півроку нас в ефірі на
Ютубі дивиться майже 370 людей зараз я
звертаюсь до них
ви можете писати запитання нашим
спікером
в коментарях
у нас в кінці передбачено блок питания
відповіді і відповідно я озвучу нашим
спікерам ваші питання а вони якщо
матимуть змогу якщо Нам дозволили час
якщо матиме час і натхнення то вони
дадуть відповідь А зараз я хочу надати
слово бачили ви слайд де ми дякували
партнерам
величезний наш партнер програма uf
Skills яка з одного боку на жаль ось-ось
закінчується буквально
останній місяць і ми останні результати
останні напрацювання Вам сьогодні
показуємо
які були розроблені спільно з партнерами
а з іншого боку ми вже маємо з окремими
колегами домовленості про подальший
розвиток і чекаємо нових
нових
нових програм нових проектів нових
здобутків так от власне хочу
запросити до слова керівника одного із
проектів програми ufuskills пана Артема
Коваля будь ласка будь ласка Артема
Дякую Олексію
шановні партнери шановні представники
закладів освіти Вітаю вас на
сьогоднішньому заході
сьогодні
сьогодні поговоримо про
поняття яке всім
викладачам і представникам закладів
освіти вже мені здається за останні роки
стало дуже відомим це
змішаний формат освіти і саме для цього
наш проект підготував посібник з
організації змішаної освіти про які я
розкажу трохи згодом проект і фоскілс в
рамках першого компоненту підвищення
ефективності професійно-технічної
реформи
активно співпрацює з закладами освіти
Ми протягом починаючи з 2017 року
реалізовували спільні проекти і надавали
допомогу закладам професійно-технічної
освіти у Вінницькій Полтавській
Рівненській Львівській Миколаївський
Чернівецький і
івано-франківській областях і
саме в результаті цієї співпраці і за
досвідом цієї співпраці був розроблений
такий посібник змішане навчання у
закладах професійно-технічної освіти
цей посібник він орієнтований перш за
все на керівників та педагогів закладів
професійно-технічної освіти і
Основна його мета - це саме
дати інструмент керівникам і педагогом
для організації ефективної та
продуктивної
змішаного навчання у закладах
професійно-технічної освіти
в даному посібнику який
поділений на три частини
першій частині ми даємо загальний огляд
змішаного навчання оріє посібник
орієнтує моделях змішаного навчання
надає поради адміністрації щодо
організації управління освітнім процесом
і
е-е в першій частині ми розповідаємо
загалом про переваги виклики та
результати досліджень
щодо імплементації елементів змішаної
освіти треба зазначити що даний посібник
він був рекомендований міністерством
освіти наприкінці
2021 року він включає в себе в основному
рекомендації які були зібрані в країнах
Європи і в Україні протягом 20-21 року
водночас колектив
укладачів він всі приклади які вказував
вказував в цьому посібнику всі приклади
взяті з українського досвіду саме Тобто
Це ті приклади які надавали наші
партнери
в Вінницькій області в
Чернівецькій області є приклади в даному
посібнику
Отже посібник як я вже сказав раніше він
розділений на три частини перша частина
- це загальний огляд організації друга
частина - це
в першій частині тут представлені моделі
змішаного навчання
по представлені дослідження як і
вказують на можливе
можливість шляхи організації і Найкраще
співвідношення очного і
онлайн нового навчання
і моделі організації віртуального
середовища друга частина цього
підручника це
рекомендації безпосередньо керівникам
закладів вищої закладу закладів
професійно-технічної освіти і
важливою частиною цього розділу є саме
приклади приклади
ефективної організації змішаної освіти в
українських закладах ПТО які були
реалізовані протягом 20-21 років
в даному в даному блоці цього посібника
розглянути такі питання як створити
стратегію змішаного навчання у певному
закладі як організувати та налаштувати
освітній процес при змішаному навчанні
як створити комфортне освітнє середовище
для всіх учасників освітнього процесу
також розглянути такі важливі питання як
оптимізація навантаження для педагогів і
для здобувачів освіти
також в даному розділі
велику увагу приділено саме успішним
кейсом і
можливості їхнього повторення в
подальшому
наступний розділ даного
посібника це
рекомендації безпосередньо педагогічному
колективу
в даному розділі велика увага приділена
організації роботи і використання
програм
softwer в
[музика]
організації процесу тут представлені
такі програми Microsoft Office 365
представлені приклади імплантації
програм різних представлені також
посилання корисні на ті
програми які можна використовувати в
освітньому процесі
також
є частина в даному розділі яка приділена
саме мотивації здобувачів освіти
мотивації саме в контексті використання
формату змішаної освіти тобто формату
коли частина навчання проходить онлайн і
ми розуміємо що не всі учасники процесу
завжди на 100% залучені тому Це також
важливо також що
дуже зручно у даному посібнику який є
доступним уже на сайті міністерства осві
ти є посилання на інші ресурси які можна
використовувати і список цікавих також
іноземних джерел які наведений в кінці
підручника на які так само можна
в свому процесі навчання використовувати
викладачам які можна також почитати
керівникам закладів освіти для
ефективної організації ефективного
навчання
зараз я
виведу на екран посилання це посилання
на повну версію за qr-кодом повну версію
самого посібника він вже є доступний він
також доступний на сторінці і у фоскілс
безпосередньо на сайті Міністерства
освіти як і всі інші матеріали які були
підготовлені проектом тому ми всіх
Запрошуємо і знову ж таки Дякуємо нашим
партнерам Міністерство за те що всі ці
інструменти були разом розроблені і
розміщені
наступний інструмент який був
розроблений в рамках проекту
Також я
продемонструвати це
посібник
посібник щодо організації дуальної форми
професійно-технічної освіти даний
посібник
він так само орієнтований на керівників
закладів професійно-технічної освіти але
також на представників бізнесу тому що
ми розуміємо що
дуальна форма професійно-технічної
освіти вона передбачає участь
компанії яка бере на себе таке
зобов'язання співпрацювати з закладом
професійно технічної освіти в даному
посібнику ми розглядаємо ну німецький
досвід в основному так само досвід
організації і в Україні вказані переваги
організації ідеальної форми
професійно-технічної освіти Окрім цього
вказані
важливі аспекти
організації Наприклад тут проведена
проведені додатки
як які можуть слугувати прикладом для
наприклад
договору
п'ятирістороннього між закладом освіти
здобувачем і роботодавцем так само
додатки
для організації самої самого навчання
Тобто там які можна взяти за основу ми
розуміємо що наразі
організувати
справжню дуальну освіту в закладах
професійно-технічної освіти може бути
досить
проблематично враховуючи економічну
ситуацію тому що ми розуміємо що
зобов'язання за фінансування дальної
освіти в ідеалі має братися на себе в
тому числі роботодавець
але все ж я
німецьке товариство міжнародного
співробітництва реалізовувало подібні
проекти уже і Я впевнений що в
майбутньому в
в тому числі на рівні
професійно-технічної освіти у нас буде
набувати
набувати поширення така форма освіти як
дуальна освіта
це ті посібники які є доступними як я
сказав на сайті Міністерства освіти в
розділі і у фоскілс і Я запрошую всіх їх
вивчати користуватися досвідом проекту
який як правильно сказав пан Олексій уже
завершується він тривало з 2017 року але
незважаючи на це новий проект з
міністерством освіти планується так само
цього року
фокус можливо буде трошки
інший тому що ми враховуємо реалії
сучасного
сучасної ситуації в якій ми зараз всі
знаходимось
тим не менш наша співпраця з партнерами
з Міністерства освіти і з інших
міністерств буде продовжуватися тому
дякую
Дякую пане Артема
дорогі друзі я
так тепер мене чути Добре
дорогі друзі Я читаю ваші коментарі
Дякую за них Дякую за вашу активність
пану Артему теж дякуював поки мікрофон
був вимкнений значить відповідаючи
наперед
на ваші запитання щодо презентації
Давайте зробимо мабуть Таким чином
після нашого вебінару Я у наших колег
попрошу їх презентації посібники
посилання і розміщу в описі під цим
відео яке ви зараз дивитесь це відео
буде збережено на YouTube каналі і в
описі під відео приблизно протягом
години Мабуть так я собі так після
вебінару Я думаю я зможу Це все зібрати
покласти десь на диски і скинути вам
посилання
А зараз я хочу запросити до слова
наступного нашого спікера пана Андрія
Дякую
Вітаю слухачів сьогоднішнього нашого
заходу і ще раз Хочу привітати з таким
чудовим святом днем тижнем професійної
освіти в Україні та презентувати
наші напрацювання які реалізовані і
зараз ще реалізуються в рамках виконання
проекту зараз запущу презентацію
так
чутно мене все видно
Так дякую
що стосується
сьогоднішньої презентації вона
пов'язана безпосередньо з
впровадженням енергоефективних
технологій в рамках реалізації проекту
підвищення
спроможності стейкхолдерів щодо
підготовки висококваліфікованих
спеціалістів у галузі енергоефективності
даний проект реалізується
міжнародною фондацією розвитку у
співпраці з німецьким товаридом
товариство міжнародного співробітництва
jс і наразі хочу ознайомити вас з
функціоналом
мобільного застосунку який створюється в
рамках реалізації цього проекту і який
направлений на
надання певних нових можливостей у
навчанні та можливості у
працевлаштування Після навчання після
навчання у сфері енергоефективності
наш мобільний застосунок має назву є
Профі Як ви бачите він має
певну таку кольорову гаму яка думає дуже
дотична до
молоді до
таких ярких вражень і можливостей що у
сфері енергоефективності що стосується
самого застосунку то він призначений для
оперативного інформування користувачів в
онлайн-режимі щодо базова кальцій у
сфері енергоефективності
пошуку роботи за професійними
кваліфікаціями та отримується які
отримують вони Після навчання також це
цей засновник має перелік закладів
освіти навчальних консультаційних
центрів професійних кваліфікацій
компанії які працюють у сфері
енергоефективності та енергозбереження
або впроваджуйте енергоефективні
технології
нашу команду розроблено структура даного
мобільного застосунка є компоненти які
пов'язані безпосередньо з його
функціонуванням це підсистеми підсистеми
підбору вакансії і резюме це підсистеми
якбову закладів освіти навчальних
консультаційних центрів а також
підсистема підбору компанії які
впроваджують енергоефективні технології
крім цього також
даний мобільний застосунок буде давати
можливість формувати оперативні звіти по
щодо використання даних ведення
довідників для забезпечення роботи
мобільного застосунку та мати окремий
систему профілю користувача
що стосується функцій підсистеми
підбору вакансії резюме Дана підсистема
буде давати можливість
пошуку вакансій по певним вказаним
користувачам критеріям пошук резюме по
вказаному критеріям це збереження також
параметрів пошуку відображення даних
відбору у профілі користувача крім цього
наш мобільному застосунком буде
можливість
взаємодіяти з електронною інформаційною
системою державної служби зайнятості для
того щоб наповнювати даний застосунок
новими вакансіями а також мати
можливість доступу до резюме осіб які
Після
навчання
надали інформацію до державної служби
зайнятості
А що стосується функції підсистеми
підбору заходів освіти і навчальних
консультаційних центрів Дана підсистема
буде також мати можливість
створення певних курсів на базі даного
мобільного застосунку і в подальшому
їх інформування користувачів про
відповідні курси які впроваджуються
навчальними центрами або іншими
закладами у сфері енергоефективності
крім цього Дана підсистема буде мати
можливість збереження відповідних
параметрів пошуку для користувача і
надасть оперативний доступ до того що
користувач собі зберігав
наступна ципом функція підсистеми
підбору компанії які впроваджуєте
енергоефективні технології Дана
підсистема також буде мати
певну структуру за вакансіями по всій
компаніїх які впроваджують
енергоефективні технології і відповідно
по критеріях можуть бути визначені
пошукові запити щодо отримання
інформації про Дані компанії також мати
функцію збереження параметрів пошуку і
відображення даних відбору у профілі
користувача
наступна - це підсистема сама система
профіль користувача - це скажімо одна з
серцевих він даного мобільного
застосунку яка буде мати можливість
розмістити інформацію щодо особистих
даних користувача
певних рекомендованих вакансій резюме
інформації щодо навчання або підвищення
кваліфікації також
мати можливість надати доступ до
довідкових ресурсів і певне події
заходів які будуть проводитись окремо
для цього плануємо
надати доступ до календаря для фіксації
цих заходів подій або інших робіт
наступне це я коротко розповім про
структуру мобільного самого мобільного
застосунку
і презентує його
візуальний Да такий огляд щодо основних
сторінок
стартова сторінка вона буде показувати
безпосередньо показує презентує
мобільний застосунок І вказуючи про що
це цей застосунок тобто як ми бачимо цей
застосунок безпосередньо про роботу Він
про освіту і про енергетичну
ефективність тобто цей застосунок якраз
впроваджує в себе комплекс таких
важливих елементів які пов'язані з
енергоефективністю
навчання і пошук роботи в цій сфері
наступне це профіль користувача профіль
користувача
буде мати
структуру яка дозволяє показати особисті
дані користувача
резюме вакансії навчання підвищення
кваліфікації і питання які стосуються
збережених пошуків відгуків календаря та
додаткових додаткових ресурсів
особистий кабінет користувача має
відповідно таку структуру Як ви бачите
тут досить прості і зрозумілі форми буде
користувач буде мати можливість
повністю розмістити всі необхідні свої
дані і отримати інформацію яка йому
допоможе в пошуку роботи або отримання
певного певних Запитів на
від компанії Або можливо навчання або
кваліфікації
також даний застосунок буде надавати
доступ користувачу для створення резюме
крім цього
користувач може мати матиме можливість
редагувати скачати це резюме в
доступному форматі для того щоб
надіслати для роботодавця відповідно
інформація і
показати досвід вже наявний у
особи з у сфері енергоефективності
наступне - це окрема структурний елемент
Для навчальних центрів і закладів освіти
навчальний центр заходи освіти має також
матимуть змогу зареєструвати себе у
даному мобільному застосунку тут як ви
бачите є перелік інформації яка може
бути вказана закладом і відповідним
чином заклад може презентувати себе для
користувачів які зареєстровані в
мобільному додатку для того щоб
показати ті навчальні програми за якими
вони готують
спеціалістів у сфері енергоефективності
також надати посилання на онлайн-курси
надати інформацію щодо проведення курсів
учних у закладах і відповідно чином
також надають нададуть можливість
показати історію успіхів випускників а
також реєстр сертифікатів якщо вони
проводять навчання за
сертифікатами програми
крім цього як ви бачите тут можна буде
будуть рекомендовані
курси а також описи вакансії якщо є
необхідність у пошуку
співробітників або робітників у сфері
енергоефективності
крім цього
буде інформація
крім цього також в даному мобільному
застосованнику буде можливість
отримати інформацію яка стосується
обраних і збережених пошуків у щодо
спеціалістів в сфері енергоефективності
Як ви бачите тут буде можливість
розмічити його за аналогічним принципом
як вказано на екрані
також даний мобільний застосунок
дозволяє надавати реєструватись і
створювати вакансії для роботодавців
Тобто це для компанії які
зацікавлені в пошуку
висококваліфікованих робітників у сфері
енергоефективності тут можна бути
додані вакансії які потрібні для
роботодавця або він може знайти резюме
по вже наявним
особам які користувачами які
зареєструвались і відібрати для себе
найкращих крім також роботодавці деякі
компанії Вони мають можливість проводити
навчання бо підвищення кваліфікації тому
будемо можливість відповідним чином для
них проводити навчання як для своїх
співробітників так і для інших осіб які
будуть зацікавлені в отриманні нових
знань або підвищення кваліфікації
Як ви бачите це теж візуалізація того
яким чином буде виглядати вакансія які
будуть розміщуватися компанії і як
користувач може їх бачити на своєму
екрані
також
що стосується
мобільного застосунку окремо і створений
можливості щодо
фільтрів певних за певними критеріями Що
дозволить дуже швидко
Щоб
дуже швидко обирати для себе або район
або регіон в якому
користувач хоче знайти роботу Або
можливо отримати інформацію про навчання
для роботодавця буде можливість в тому
числі мати доступ до резюме
пошуковому фільтрам регіону міста
зайнятості і зарплати бажаної і інших
критеріях які будуть більш деталізувати
можливість пошукового запиту для
користувачів додатку
Наразі це
все хочу також зазначити що
даний додаток він застосунок розроблений
за підтримки
німецького товариства міжнародного
співробітництва jс у співпраці з
міністерством освіти і науки України
державної служби зайнятості федерації
роботодавців України та впроваджуються
організації міжнародна Федерація
розвитку
безпосередньо розробниками є компанії
які залучені до
технічної розробки безпосередньо цього
мобільного застосунку це сайт пбт та avb
Soft Well Solutions
Дякую це у мене все з презентацією І я
також
хотів коротко ще
пошарити відео для того щоб наші слухачі
могли побачити яким чином зараз вже
наявний даний застосунок як він у нас
як його можна побачити зараз вже
візуально
вітаємо у світі енерфективності нового
покоління є Профі мобільний застосунок
створений спеціально для фахівців у
галузі на розбереження
є профіль об'єднує в собі всі сучасні
інструменти для отримання знань у сфері
енергоефективності розміщення вакансії
пошуку роботи або можливостей для
підвищення кваліфікації а зручний
інтерфейс та модуль між функцій
забезпечують максимальну продуктивність
роботи не є Профі є вікно акаунту в
якому ви з легкістю зможете скористатись
функціоналом який ви зацікавите Ви
колись задоволець підтягнути своє знання
з енергоефективності без проблем не є
пропів ви зможете знайти багато
різноманітних курсів від різних
навчальних закладів
створюєте та робити особисті резюме з
легкістю отримуйте нескінченні
можливості та вражайте роботодавця
Почніть будувати свою кар'єру просто
зараз
ви хотіли створити свою власну резюме це
просто в нас є можливість створювати
резюме а також редагувати або
переглядати ви шукаєте кваліфікованих
працівників для виконання робіт з
енергозбереження це швидко і профіль
можна створити необхідні вакансії а
також мати доступ до резюме
зареєстрованих експертів та робітників
є профіль енергоефективність дорога до
твого майбутнього
Так дякую Це був коротка коротке
відеоролик презентацію нашого мобільного
застосунку
Дякую всім за увагу
Дякуємо пану Андрію знову ж таки
зважаючи на кількість реакцій в
коментарях маю вам сказати що застосунок
ваш викликаний аби яке зацікавлені
там же ж питали чи можна його скачати на
Play Market Так і як шукати
Я думаю теж Ми цю інформацію додамо якщо
можна коротко скажу про те що даний
мобільний застосунок Він ще в стадії
тестування то тому він буде доступний
через місяць може трошки більше але я
вже думаю що ми його презентуємо і
надамо всю інформацію для всіх
зацікавлених сторін десь орієнтовно у
липні місяці коли буде відбудеться
офіційна презентація із можливістю його
завантаження у Плей Маркеті і Apple
Store Запрошуйте нас на презентацію щоб
ми могли донести цю інформацію до
працівників закладів професійної освіти
А зараз я хочу запросити до слова пані
Тетяну Чернецьку
з
доповіддю з презентацією щодо проведення
гендерного аудиту в закладах професійної
освіти прошу вас остання Тетяна Дякую
пане Олексію Доброго дня шановні
учасниці та учасниці
всеукраїнського тижня професійної освіти
Дозвольте привернути вашу увагу до такої
тематики як впровадження гендерної
рівності
того моменту як Україна
стала кандидатом у ЄС вона дуже активно
Почала займатися новиною до цього
займалася але зараз активізували свою
діяльність стосовно впровадження
гендерної рівності
зрозуміло що ці процеси також торкаються
і сфери освіти Можливо ви знаєте що 20
грудня 2022 року Кабінету Міністрів
України було укладе стратегію
впровадження гендерної рівності в сфері
освіти до 2030 року а також операційний
план з реалізації цієї стратегії на 2022
24 роки мета цієї стратегії полягає у
забезпеченні рівних прав та можливості
жінок та чоловіків у запобіганні та
протидії
будь-які дискримінації в сфері освіти на
будь-якому рівні освіти через
впровадження через зміни точніше
структурну організаційних та
змістовно-процесуальних аспектах освіти
це так прописано і також у цій стратегії
зазначено що
[музика]
процеси такої наскрізності
забезпечення принципів рівних прав та
можливості жінок і чоловіків будуть
забезпечилитися в тому числі через
проведення гендерного аудиту тобто я
хочу показати що генд це не просто якась
там вигадка наприклад там
центрогендерної культури або якихось
гендерних експертів це частина державної
стратегії
крім того ще 5 листопада 2021 року
Міністерство освіти і науки видало наказ
номер 1182 про затвердження методології
та критеріїв проведення гендерного
аудиту закладів освіти тобто і мається
на увазі що всі заклади освіти незалежно
від рівня будуть
зобов'язані провести у той самий
гендерний аудит причому у наказіон
зазначається що
гендерне аудит буде проводитися шляхом
самооцінювання тобто проводити його
мають самі співробітники та
співробітники
співробітниці закладів в тому числі
професійної професійно-технічної освіти
зрозуміло що рівень знань взагалі
які-небудь досвід проведення таких
аудитів у співробітників співробітниць
сфери освіти взагалі відсутні особливо
це стосується профтехосвіти і тому в
межах
програми і UFO Skills краще навички для
сучасної України
експертками центру гендерної культури
були
розроблені по-перше це дистанційний курс
гендерне аудит у закладах професійної
професійної технічної освіти які уже
згадувала сьогодні пані Анна а також
розроблена посібник з проведення
комплексного гендерного аудиту у
закладах професійної професійної
технічної освіти тому Наразі я хочу вам
продемонструвати
як виглядає Цей курс для того щоб
заохотити вас все-таки користуватися і
використовувати ці от напрацювання У
вашій подальшій роботі в тих гендерних
аудитах які ви будете проводити Як ви
бачите розташоване він на платформі
профосвіта онлайн Про яку ви вже
сьогодні чули складається Цей курс із 10
модулів можна умовно поділити його на
дві частини перша частина з 1 по 5
модуль - це
загальні такі
загальна інформація про гендерну теорію
тобто тут ви зможете дізнатися про те
наприклад що таке гендер чим
відрізняється гендер із стат що таке
гендерна соціалізація гендерні ролі що
таке гендерна нерівність та гендерна
дискримінація як вони взагалі в чому
вони проявляються І що з цим можна
робити яке існує законодавче підґрунтя
гендерної рівності міжнародні документи
які існують Які існують національні
документи як взагалі в Україні виглядає
державна гендерна політика
також один із модулів присвячених
гендерну чутливій мові тобто яким чином
мають себе поводити викладачі викладачки
в аудиторії щоб не продукувати якісь
сексистки сексистські жарти наприклад
або не транслювати стереотипи які всі у
всіх у нас є але хоча б аудиторії не
демонструвати їх також цегендировані
сторінку праці гендерні стереотипи при
виборі професій чому ми
[музика]
в курсі які
присвячені гендерному аудиту цілих 5
модулів вирішили присвятити саме на наш
погляд проводити гендерна аудит якщо у
вас взагалі не розвинена гендерна
чутливість тобто коли вони бачите
гендерної нерівності гендерної
дискримінації буде доста тньо складно
тому ми починаємо з цього наступні 5
модулів вони власне присвячені саме
таким алгоритмом і методиці проведення
комплексного гендерного аудиту у
закладах профтехосвіти як виглядає Цей
курс Він має достатньо таку багато
по-перше це ролики я вам Хочу запустити
от перший
[музика]
на те якою людиною стане дитина впливає
також наявність суспільній свідомості
гендерних стереотипів
гендерні стереотипи - це стінки уявлення
про характеристики якості і моделі
поведінки людей за ознакою статі як
правило гендерні стереотипи стосуються
двох речей це по-перше зовнішність
чоловіків та жінок або розподілення
гендерних ролей у суспільстві
суспільні свідомості патріархатного
суспільства закріплені стійкі уявлення
що жінка має бути в красивою доглянутою
Вона має бути хорошою господинею і
матір'ю для дітей причому обов'язково
мати дітей тобто в кожному
модулі є декілька відео в яких Ну тут ви
бачите якісь
більш-менш теоретичні тільки
висвітлюється а також є якась
візуалізація цього окрім того після
кожного невеличкого відео У нас є такі
питання для обговорення питання для
роздумів точніше щоб трошки
порексувати стосовно того що ви побачили
також пропонується матеріали для
самостійного опрацювання це і посібники
і так само це можуть бути якісь
відеоматеріали наприклад от посилання на
музей жіночої та гендерної історії на
віртуальні експозицію дещо про гендер і
тут ви можете побачити вже і ролики і
також
є і тести і просто якісь визначення
наприклад що таке гендер що таке
гендерні ролі тощо і кожен з модулів
завершується невеличким тестом це
буквально 5 запитань на які потрібно
дати відповіді для того щоб в подальшому
це зарахувалося і ми спо вчимося буде
можливість генерування сертифікатів для
тих хто
передивиться
даний курс Ну і виконає якісь завдання
які тут мають місце бути 5
наступних
модулів присвячених як я вже сказала
саме тому як проводиться гендерний аудит
тут достатньо конкретно розібране ну
по-перше мова йде про яка мета
гендерного аудиту для чого взагалі він
потрібний який з яких етапів він
складається теми якісь технічні моменти
пов'язаний з тим як формулювати
формулювати робочу групу
Всі ці речі Вони також
відображені у посібнику
посібник ви зможете побачити от одразу
під наприклад Під самим під цим 6
модулем ви бачите посібник з проведення
комплексного гендерного аудиту
навчального закладу цей посібник також
він розміщений на сайті Міністерства
освіти і науки я передам Олексію всі
посилання вони будуть під цим відео і в
цьому посібнику Ну по суті він трошки
доповнює
відеокурс тому що люди різні сприйняття
різних комусь легко сприймати саме
візуальну інформацію просто там комусь
аудіо інформації комусь потрібно
обов'язково мати перед собою тексти Тому
цей посібник Він повторює структуру
курсу і тут вже на наш погляд достатньо
конкретно
прописана сама процедура Ну наприклад ви
можете побачити от сам аналіз даних той
який відбуваються тут прописано те як як
в Екселі можна
такими простими методами да аналізувати
ці дані які ви зможете отримати то ми
сподіваємося що цей по сібник він буде
для вас дійсно корисним і допоможе в
проведенні
комплексного гендерного аудиту ще я хочу
звернути вашу увагу на ще одну нашу таку
розробку тут або такий пакет скоріше
документів які ми зробили Тобто ми
намагалися зробити все щоб цей курс Він
був дуже таким
практичним тобто щоб ви не просто
прослухали а могли і проводячи гендер на
аудит могли б звертатися до тих
інструментів які тут присутні наприклад
є папочка інструменти для проведення
гендерного аудиту
і тут ми зібрали для вас спеціально всі
всю інформацію ну точніше всі от бланки
всі анкети які можна використовувати
точніше ми рекомендуємо використовувати
для проведення гендерного аудиту у
закладах професійної
професійно-технічної освіти причому є
також тут анкета от анкета для
викладацького складу наприклад це анкети
які вже зроблені онлайн і ви можете
просто їх собі скопіювати і далі
розсилати тобто дуже легко вам не
потрібно буде витрачати час на те щоб
самостійно робити якісь там анкети а
потім
уже їх намагатися обробляти тобто все
воно вже для вас підготовлено і таким
чином ми сподіваємося що це дійсно
допоможе вам в
проведенні комплексного гендерного
аудиту
всі посилання як я вже сказала я вже я
вам надам і якщо будуть виникати якісь
питання ми також є адміністратор ми
цього курсу ми будемо брати участь
підтримувати модерувати обговорення які
там сподіваємося будуть відбуватися і ми
сподіваємося що дійсно Цей
ці інструменти вони допоможуть нам з
вами разом впроваджувати гендерну
рівності з теми професійної професійної
технічної освіти Я вам бажаю успіхів на
цьому нелегкому шляху до гендерної
рівності не лише в системі а також і в
суспільстві загалом Дякую за увагу
ми вам теж Дякуємо пані Тетяна
за змістом за змістовну доповідь справді
як для себе навіть дещо нового дізнався
А зараз я хочу
запросити до слова
одного з розробників курсів на нашій
платформі
власне на всього на сьогодні мабуть
найбільшого розробника та
якщо взяти одного конкретно розробника
то найбільше
курсів на нашій платформі і найкращі
курси я на мою особисту думку яким я
найбільше горджуся
розробив пан Юрій зубань спільно з
колегами і давайте послухаємо що ж
нового з'явилось на нашій платформі
прошу пане Юрій
Добрий день шановні колеги приємно чути
таку високу оцінку я моя презентація
буде у відеоформаті і тому я трішки
Хвилююся про
те щоб трансляція відбувалася
максимально якісно і під час цих
відеопрезентацій якщо будуть якісь
затримки або звук буде заважати ви мені
одразу зупиняєте і кажіть я буду
коригувати на ходу добре потім я поширюю
цю Це
відеоматеріал для того щоб всі могли
його передивитися ще у спокійному
режимі Отже
нашою командою було загалом розроблено
онлайн курсів з 10 професій як вже була
анонсована хочу сказати що всі ці курси
були розроблені на професійному рівні у
співпраці з
найдосвідченішими авторами які вже
багато років
викладають ці дисципліни в закладах
професійно-технічної освіти мають досвід
роботи
курси представляють собою повноцінний
навчально-медичний комплекс який
орієнтований на ті результати навчання
які можна досягти в онлайн форматі вони
не зазіхають на мануальні навички які
напрацювується в аудиторії курси
орієнтовані саме на онлайн формат
структура курсів створена таким чином що
вона чітко визначає результати навчання
у дисципліні по курсу а також
структуру кожного курсу з відповідними
теорети матеріалами інтерактивними
завданнями різного формату відео Тобто
це повноцінний комплекс Ну і завершиться
рефлексивними завданнями Сьогодні я
хотів би звернути увагу на мобільний
симулятор за допомогою реальністю які
розроблені для 5
для 5 курсів це два симулятори для
слюсаря з ремонту рухомого складу які
якраз і орієнтовані на вивчення будови
конструкції тепловоза а також
технологічних процесу його демонтажу
ремонту і монтажу вісків рухомого складу
це і навчальний симулятор який дозволяє
на опанувати навички і технологічні
етапи прокладання електричних проводок
навчальний симулятор з вивчення
конструкції і будови універсального
гвинторізного
верстату пам'ятаю в даному випадку у нас
16к20 а також
багато
верстатів для обробки деревини
Отже що таке докона реальність як вона
працює для тих хто не має не мав досвіду
застосування таких застосунків це
виглядає з боку саме таким чином через
екран вашого планшета чи телефона
учень спостерігає віртуальні моделі
віртуальні
сцени з нашим верстатом і тепловозами
тощо для цього знадобиться вільний
простір в кімнаті для того щоб можна
було вільно рухатися особливістю до
повної реальності якраз є те що
ваші рухи по кімнаті в реальному
просторі співпадають повністю
синхронізовані з рухами у віртуальному
віртуальній площині Коли ви наближаєтесь
до тепловоза чи верстата чи якогось
іншого об'єкта то ви наближаєтесь і до
віртуальної моделі От такий великий
тепловоз довжина якого 22 метри
вкрай важко дослідити в онлайні в себе
вдома але за допомогою симулятора це
можна зробити Ну от приклад
ви бачите що до нього можна підійти
роздивитися і першим першим завданням
тобто першим режимом роботи який
застосовується до всіх наших симуляторів
це режим ознайомлення коли можна дійсно
зручний спосіб як вам учні сподобається
підійти нахилитися з будь-якого ракурсу
роздивитися об'єкт вивчення чи то
верстат чи тепловоз чи то приміщення
новобудови там де проводиться
про електропроводки з верстатами і з
об'єктами з усіма об'єктами можна
взаємодіяти саме в цьому і їх
особливість
в рамках вивчення конструкції
передбачена саме
рухомість і взаємодія з тими елементами
які потрібно знати учням органи
управління верстатом з яких складових
він складається що в ньому рухається що
в ньому не рухається Ну от наприклад ви
бачите можна
розблокувати і змінювати місце тримачі і
змінювати різці не верстата ось ми зараз
вмикаємо Я сподіваюсь ви чуєте шум
двигуна
я поширюю звук щоб
просто вже пісні елементи
музичного мистецтва
[музика]
буде
зменшувати Так отже ви бачите що
елементи можна рухати і головна задача
це перше знайомство і
розуміння що учня очікуватиме в реальній
навчальній лабораторії і аудитор у
коридорі має бути квартирний щиток щиток
Я хочу сховати за формою
електромонтажника бо його реальним
об'єктом буде якась новобудова
приміщення А також
для загального освіти пояснює дещо в
нього має бути розміщений яке
електричні прилади не вимикач і дати
можливість у такому віртуальному
способів себе майбутнім уже фахівцем
який спочатку слухає розмічає робить
якісь позначки на стінах
згідно з монтажною схемою
власниці
студія тут буде робоча частина кухні я
планую що тут мають бути розетки для
підключення різних кухонних
електроприладів і хочу мати тут
додаткову освітлення робочої зони може
спробувати в такому ігровому режимі
виконувати ці симулятори стільки
поки він не зрозумів в цьому місці поки
стояти варочна поверхня я планую
поставити індукційну плитку впливає на
податку і над плитою хочу мати витяжну
шафу одразу скажу
що працює кожен симулятор зберігає
результати по кожному етапу
неподалік плити буде посудомийна машина
та мікрохвильова в курсах буде
викладачу і учні видно
відсоток опрацювання кожного з етапів
симуляторів
для мене буде знаходитись холодильник
навпроти буде обідній стіл над яким я
хочу повісити люстру для кухні
[музика]
в іншій частині кухні-студії зона
відпочинку тут буде стояти диван а
навпроти нього на стіні телевізор Мені
знизу потрібно подвійна розетка для
підключення телевізора
[музика]
вимикач для включення освітлення на
балконі має знаходитися з правої сторони
дверей
типом завдань які можуть виконуватися
підготуйся до виконання робіт
Отже наступним етапом важливим є
демонстрація будови у максимально
наочний спосіб так званий інструктаж чи
пояснення це те що зазвичай викладачі
майстер робить в навчальній лабораторії
чи аудиторії в майстерні для того щоб
максимально великовий верстат
призначений для поздовжнього і
поперечного розпилювання а також
розпилювання під кутом пиломатеріалів
їх багато в курсі стимуляторів даного
верстата є тканина
робочий стіл
Пильний диск
направляючи реалізували можливість
підсвічування елементу конструкції на
який наводить
популярною екрана симулятора чи можливо
трансляція і поширені ваших екрана в
онлайн для того щоб не працювати
що той елемент праворуч у Верхньому
куточку
за допомогою симулятора ви конкретно
позиціонуєте і фокусуєте симулятор на
той чи інший елемент конструкції
кнопка зупинка
[музика]
маховик регулювання кута нахилу пильного
диска
маховик для регулювання пильного диска
по висоті
каретка за допомогою якої можна
виконувати якісне торцювання заготовок
лінійка каретки і упор
елементами захисту у цьому верстаті є
кожух і розклинювальний ніж до кожуха
під'єднана аспірація для видалення
відходів
аспірація має свої кнопки пуск і зупинка
якими здійснюється її вмикання і
вимикання
елементів
конструктивними частинами цього верстата
є станина
робочий стіл
[музика]
кожен деревообробний верстат має свою
особливу конструкцію ріжучий інструмент
фреза яка встановлюється на шпиндері
скоба
конструктивних елементів складається
рукоятки фіксації скоби
налаштування і в якій послідовності тому
вивчення будови є
переміщуючи скобу Можна налаштувати
потрібну глибину фрезерування
деревини на верстатах
направляючи лінійки
рукоятки фіксації лінійок
лінійки налаштовуються під різні
діаметри фрез
[музика]
каретка на якій розміщена лінійка з
опорами
[музика]
каретку можна пересувати відносно фрези
маховик яким здійснюється регулювання
призи по висоті
[музика]
передня шпиндельна бабка це корисні
токарного верстата призначений для
передачі заготовці обертального руху це
чавунна коробка усередині якої міститься
головний робочий орган верстата шпина
коробка зазирнути всередині цієї
шпиндильний бабки передньої бабки і
подивитися
що знаходиться всередині Шпиндель це
основна частина токарні елементи
у процесах де знаходиться той елемент
значення Зараз для фіксації оброблюваної
заготовки електронні та передачі на неї
обертального моменту від електродвигуна
із себе реальними кістки не можемо
побачити не розібравши конструкцію
коробка подач служить для зміни величини
подачі для налаштування на тип і на крок
різьби
задня бабка - це вузол токарного
верстата для фіксації оброблюваних
заготовок за допомогою опорного або
обертового центру і також
використовується для встановлення
ріжучого інструменту та
свердлзенкерів розгорток
супорт - це вузол Який необхідний для
кріплення інструмента та автоматичного
чи ручного його переміщення на верстаті
найчастіше супорт складається зріс
цетримача та додаткових деталей типу
полосків які забезпечують потрібний
напрямок руху інструмента
поперечний супорт - це механізм
пов'язаний з напрямними поздовжнього
супорта який задає напрямок поворотній
плиті та верхньому супорту зрісться
тримачем
головна рама призначена для монтажу
обладнання та кузова тепловоза а також
для передачі тяги і гальмівний
до візків за допомогою восьми підвісних
болтів
необхідні елементи їх назви от
підвіскатний пристрій
забезпечуєте автоматичне з'єднання
одиниці рухомого складу утримання їх на
певній відстані один від одного передачу
сил в поїзді і пом'якшення дії цих сил
на рухомий склад кузов капотного типу
захищає обладнання тепловоза та
локомотивну бригаду від впливу
зовнішнього середовища кузов поділений
на чотири кузовим передній кузов кузов
машинного відділення кабіна машиніста в
якій розміщуються пульт управління та
задній кузов
наступним елементом чи типом активностей
які виконуються на симуляторі це вже є
перевірка
знань будови тобто назвемо Так це
3d-тести коли необхідно зорієнтуватися в
просторі і знайти ту деталь чи ту
складову елемента конструкції
про яку стоїть питання Ну от якраз на
прикладі нашого тепловоза який дуже
великий
питання бачите озвучене на екрані ця
рама призначена для встановлення
колінчатого валу тобто є цільове
призначення елементу і треба знайти усі
Ці конструкції а конструкція дуже
об'ємна і велика нагадую 22 метри
довжину отак виділивши і
давши відповідь можна
показати Я хотів би ще раз показати ось
елементи
навігації в цьому симуляторі тому що він
дійсно має дуже величезну величезний
розмір і не у кожного учня вдома є
вільного простору 22 метри хіба що це в
навчальному закладі можливість для того
щоб
переміщуватися навколо тепловоза зручно
В нашому симуляторі розміщені такі
червоні кулі які кулі телепортації ви
бачите вони на різних рівнях тому що
тепловоз ще і високий Він має три рівні
висоти клікнувши на таку червону кульку
ми туди стрибаємо переміщуємося саме в
ту позицію в ту локацію зараз побачите
на верхній рівень ми перейшли і ми
опинилися над дизелем тепловоза і можемо
розглядати його зверху це унікальна
можливість тому що для того щоб так
роздивитися реальні технології вам
знадобиться загнати його у
спеціалізованого депо ремонтне на
відповідні естакади які чекають
можливість доступу до Верхнього рівня ми
ж можемо стимуляторі роздивлятися бачите
опуститися на нижній рівень можна
опуститися на рівень візків і
обстежувати
наш тепловоз з будь-якої ракурсу
результатом проходження тесту буде
певний відсоток правильних певний
відсоток неправильних і відносно
правильних і неправильних відповідей це
є результат відправляється в курс
автоматично і вже в онлайн-курсі Ми
бачимо результат виконання
найцікавішою найскладнішою частиною
симуляторів є інтерактивні вправи які
фактично передбачають собою певну
послідовність дій у відповідності до
технології то певної технологічної карти
чи інструкції що в якій послідовності
має виконуватися
В якості прикладу той самий
тепловоз Я трішки повільніше зроблю
операція з
демонтажу ремонту та монтажу візків
рухомого складу передбачає цілу низку
операції які виконуються для того щоб
підготувати
візки до розбирання для цього
піднімається на домкратах кузов
тепловози
правильними інструментами у Кожен
елемент
розбирається за допомогою правильних
ключів тут показано зараз спрощене така
пришвидшена послідовність дій коли ми
підняли кузов і побачили візки
наступний
симулятор взагалі побудований на всіх
таких послідовностях коли треба знати що
в якій послідовності робиться це якраз
електромонтажник який має зробити
декілька етапів для виконання прихованої
розмітки перший етап цей етап розмічання
на етапі розмічання
необхідно застосовувати інструменти такі
як лазерний нівелір вимірювальний
пристрій рулетка чи лінійка олівець та
шаблон за допомогою шаблони учень
розміщає місця
[музика]
де будуть розташовані підроззитники та
монтажні коробки за допомогою лазерної
нівелірної він може відвідати правильні
вертикальні та горизонтальні лінії
місце розташування майбутніх строгом і
під
провідні траси кабелів
олівець бачите буквально початок кінець
позначили олівцем провели згідно тих
позначок якими зробили раніше згідно
монтажної схеми яка є в розпорядженні
учнів курсі тобто такий симулятор в
першу чергу тренує уяву і асоціації між
монтажною схемою
і реальне приміщенням віртуальне
приміщенням в якому має здійснюватися
має здійснюватися електромонтажні роботи
після таких маніпуляцій при правильному
виконанні розмічальних робіт та
порозничання
наступними етапом технологічним є
Пробивні роботи які зараз будуть також
продемонстровані
[музика]
інструменти євро спорядження Вони
обираються ж треба різними роблять це
відповідні
маніпуляції для
перфоратора вибираються штроби
[музика]
Юрію паузу нажміль будь ласка Та я з
вашого дозволу з глядачам які дивляться
в Facebook коротеньку інформацію озвучу
там це
З певних причин Ми мусимо зупинити
трансляцію на Facebook але на Ютубі цей
запис буде тому всі хто дивляться зараз
Facebook ви зможете потім
зайти прям або прямо зараз в Ютубі в
YouTube на канал man і
завершити перегляд нашого вебінару Дякую
Юрію Продовжуйте
під час виконання таких дій важливо є
також вибір правильно інструменту ви
бачите У нас тут є три різних
перфоратори для виконання отворів під
розетників вимикачі один з них є з
пошкоджений ізоляція інший має
неправильну коронку якщо підійти ближче
то ми побачили що вони дійсно візуально
відрізняються до чого призводить вибір
неправильно
ви бачите
зіпсований б'ється струмом
неправильне коронка просто не сверлить
отвори і тільки правильний
перфоратор дозволяє зробити отвори під
монтажні коробки і
всі ці правильні і неправильні дії
враховуються загальний результат тобто
кількість неправильних спроб вона
зменшує відсоток виконання завдання тому
завжди буде можливість для вдосконалення
після проведення етапу пробивних робіт
наступає фінальний етап монтажу
відповідно
коробок і вони фіксується на гіпсову
суміш а також монтажу
кабельних каналів
штрафи і кабелі
На цьому етапі
учень
згідно вибраних строп має
зорієнтуватися яку довжину довжину гофри
відрізати яку довжину кабеля який тип
кабеля має підходити до дії чи іншої
того чи іншої іншого сегмента
електромережі то яку він проводить
інформацію про довжину штроби згідно
цієї довжини він відрізає
правильної довжини гофру
після цього підходить обирає заглядаючи
в монтажну схему специфікацію який же
кабель йому потрібен
2-3-4 жильний який перетин табеля
візуально чи позначкам дивиться і
відрізає за умови пральної довжини він
може вкласти вже такий підготовлений
вкладений в штробов кабель у
відповідного кабель відповідно
все вже зафіксовано ми бачимо в кінці
кабеля в обох коробках
Ну і мабуть така
важливе питання де ж ці симулятори
знаходяться і як їх запустити симулятор
є невід'ємною частиною кожного курсу в
кожному курсі є завдання які виконуються
в симуляторі фактично симулятор - це є
один з засобів навчання в кожному
симуляторі кожному завданні є такий
qr-код який містить посилання для
завантаження симулятора а також цей
qr-код містить інформацію про
користувача для його ідентифікації
для курсу для того щоб результати
виконання операції користувачем
симуляторі були інтегровані і підтягнуті
синхронізовані автоматично з
результатами в самому курсі тому я тут
свій qr-код трішечки бачите затулив для
того щоб ніхто від мого імені нічого не
виконував
qr-код єдиний він автоматично
переадресовує на відповідний маркет чи
Play Market для завантаження симулятора
Ну і маючи другу мету цей ідентифікація
в процесі виконання зараз у кожному
завданні є невеличкий відеоінструкція
виглядає приблизно цей процес Таким
чином після першої інсталяції симулятора
таке віконце яке дозволяє ідентифікувати
користувача на мобільному телефоні якщо
ми відкрили симулятор не на комп'ютері а
прямо на тому ж самому смартфоні то є
можливість спочатку завантажити зробити
скріншот
сторінки з qr-кодом собі в галерею а
потім завантажити вручну вже в симулятор
якщо це у вас буде все на одному
пристрої Тому цей момент також
врахований
ну невеличка демонстрація яким чином це
інтеграція працює той самий тепловоз ми
в структурі курсу
маємо завдання вона сканується
відповідно бачимо перелік якийсь там
завдань виконуємо ці завдання
питання правильної неправильні
фіксується обраховується відсоток і в
результаті по завершенню 79% симуляторі
вони фактично протягом там секунди
з'являються і в курсі від результату
qr-кодом та ваш найкращий результат За
це завдання 79%. наступна спроба
виконання цього завдання
на симуляторі якщо вона буде кращою
Наприклад
81%. то воно автоматично перепише і
підтягне краще результат виконувати
тобто кількість спроб
необмежено виконувати завдання можна
настільки вистачає терпіння часу аби
учень досконалюватися от показано що
навіть по одному
верстату є і огляд і будова і тести
тобто завдання навіть по одному
симулятору багато я можу зараз показати
ще
вже вживу Ось у нас етапи монтажу
електросвітлювальних проводок ви бачите
що є якісь теоретичний короткий матеріал
потім наступний етап це в нас розмітка
те що я показував на відео і коли ми
дивимося про розмітку невеличке відео
тут у нас от якраз завдання розмітка і
передбачає мабуть треба навити
сторіночку
не вдалося мені це тестової платформа бо
в мене відкрита
тобто курс містить не одне
3-4-5 інколи навіть 10 інтерактивних
завдань які виконуються в симуляторі
Вони мають відправку посилання на
симулятор зворотнім зв’язком з
симулятора по результату У такий спосіб
і реалізовані наші симулятори до повної
реальності і я сподіваюся що вони будуть
максимально ефективними для наших учнів
дякую
перепрошую за затримку бо в мене ж тут
цей студія з другого боку стрім поки всі
кнопки нажмеш то включаєш там
Дякуємо не знаю чи вражені ви маєте на
увазі глядачі так як вражений я Ну але
завжди на коментарі Да я хотів от як це
до того як ви розказали що
симулятори вбудовані безпосередньо в
курсі це в мене до вас було запитання
типу вікторина угадай угадайте скільки
разів до того як ви згадали де де
розташовані симулятори це запитання
прозвучало в чаті
було витримати і до кінця
була витримана так як треба і
наступне запитання там ціле море
побажання з приводу того щоб ми
розробляли такі симулятори і для
наступних професій от дорогі друзі в
інтернеті
тримаю тримаю перед очима ваш чат і у
нас з вами затримочка між тим як я тут
говорю і прямим ефіром десь секунд 40 Я
думаю 30-40 так зважайте будь ласка на
це от я поки озвучу ті запитання які
звучали до цього значить
найближче це
сертифікати з приводу курсу гендерної
рівності значить технічно ця опція вже є
реалізованою на платформі
Аня зараз буде посміхатись тому що у нас
це довгі дискусії з приводу того
хто якби хто має виписувати так тому
буквально буквально найближчим часом Ми
з паперової з паперового боку
вирішимо Остаточно я як це має правильно
бути зроблено і вже найближчим часом всі
курси на платформі в яких передбачено
видачу сертифікатів отримують цю
можливість Значить ще у мене було
запитання
з приводу розмістити свої курси на
платформі
це другий
нє мабуть найбільше найбільше Я горжусь
все-таки тими курсами які наші викладачі
самі розробили от А пан Юрій на другому
місці Пробачте
значить це другий найбільший момент я
дуже горжусь тими курсами які розробили
наші викладачі
але це була спеціальна програма ви чули
Аня розказувала Так це була спеціальна
навчальна програма де ми з величезною
кількістю бажаючих відібрали меншу
кількість тих хто пішов на цей курс і з
них із 40 учасників курсу лише 15
розробили курси які
за якісними критеріями за критеріями
виконання відповідають
вимогам того щоб їх можна було
розмістити в загальний загальний доступ
тому для того щоб
зробити цю історію масовою в розділі я
можу навіть
спробувати показати Зараз гляну що в
мене є є здається
Ось будь ласка
ось наша платформа в онлайні так і тут є
розділ для педагогів і керівників
закладів
і ось тут є курс про створення освітніх
онлайн-продуктів
зараз на базі цього курсу ми робимо
сертифікаційний курс в якій після
завершення якого
буде ми робимо спеціально окрему
пісочницю да спеціально окремий тестове
середовище
де ви зможете тренуватись створювати Ці
курси І після того
відповідно вони розміщуватимуться на
платформі якщо якщо ж у вас є вже
розроблені курси і ви вважаєте що їх вже
можна
розмістити на платформі то я вам
пропоную зв'язатися з нашою Анною
Так Ми мабуть
бо я поштову скриньку Ані теж
розміщу в описі цього відео от ви
зможете з нею сконтактувати вона
віддасть відповідно У нас є дві
експертних групи експертна група по
змісту освітніх матеріалів і експортна
група по технічному
виконанні і люди люди розглянуть
можливість перенесення ваших курсів на
платформу вже Давайте я буду читати ще
які є запитання
значить десь десь десь було
симулятор всіх професій це он можете
поки я поки я гортаю запитання пане Юрію
Розкажіть будь ласка
колегам в ефірі скільки часу займає
зробити там якісь маленькі симулятори
кажуть зробіть симулятори для всіх
професій для однієї професії скільки це
часу
значною вірою залежить не на технічному
рівні для від створення сценарію тобто
щоб автори розуміли що конкретно ви там
хочемо показати в якій послідовності
тобто треба як сценарій фільму Так само
і сценарій симулятора Треба чітко
описати тому тут багато ще залежати ми
від людей які здатні чітку чітку задачі
зробити от На цьому етапі ми показуємо
одне
говоримо про такі речі підписати які
даємо а тут послідовність дій має бути
такою тому А загалом десь мінімум
півроку треба на один симулятор
але в нас є там бачив коментарі по
кухарям і по і по кравцям
симулятори і Мабуть вони ще просто не
оприлюднені Але ж вони розроблені Так є
там симулятори зроблені самі матеріали
курси вимагають доопрацювання тому вони
ще не Немає його доступі ми можемо у
ванні запитати Да у нас 67 станом на
сьогодні курсів це в житті до яких всі
мають доступ А скільки ще в розробці
ними
цілому середовищі в тестовому середовищі
Це ті які вже розроблені і чекають
затвердження затвердження да от А
мікрокурси по мікрокваліфікаціям
скільки їх там ще має бути 8 о тобто
чуєте ми постійно постійно над цим
працюємо це несторі не буває не буває як
Ну не знаю От Це дійсно от я дивлю я
дивлюсь на цей контент Я дивлюсь от пані
Тетяна там вона гортала гортала свій
курс показувала
пан Юрій я дивлюсь на цей контент Ну він
класний тобто я ну не маю не те що в
Україні до нас приходили звернення
люди які виїхали у зв'язку з війною та
виїхали в Європу нема нема в Європі за
безплатно Там без грошей
матеріалів такої якості за професією
очевидно що це займає дуже багато часу
підготувати підготувати ці всі матеріали
але ми стараємось Чесно чесно пане Юрію
до вас наступне питання
наскільки вимогливий симулятор до ПК
не вимогливий тому що запускається на
мобільному телефоні це Смартфони які
підтримують допомірність одразу скажу що
смартфони бувають різні з різними
версіями Android і
iOS тому
частина
на сьогоднішній день мабуть більшість
десь половина мабуть моделей смартфонів
повинні вже підтримувати
допомірність на той випадок якщо учні
наприклад не підтримується така
технологія
симулятори передбачають там на
скріншотах на відео було видно що можна
розлогинитися тобто вийти від
користувача там наприклад Юрій і зайти
користувачем Олексію відсканувавши
qr-коди з
сторінки в курсі іншого користувача і в
принципі якщо мова йде про якийсь там
знаєте колаборацію то я думаю що завжди
можна дійти якоїсь поро розуміння і
тренуватися навіть Веселіше буде гуртом
з двох-трьох У кого кращий можливо
смартфон то виконувати ці проходити
симулятори по черзі там врешті-решті
якось так тому є можливість виконувати
від імені різних осіб на смартфон Але я
думаю що через рік таких смартфонів буде
ще більше в рази і ми сюди рухаємося
тому що всі розробники передбачають
застосування до повноряності багато чого
не тільки вони навчають
Так тут пан Олександр Швець питає чи не
кращі гроші які витрачені на симулятори
за ці гроші створити дітям реальне
середовище де вони могли б заробляти
самі гроші практикуючи цю професію
це філософське питання ми вчимось ми
вчимось Я маю на увазі директора
професійної освіти розробники наші
вчаться ми тобто якщо
Спочатку
ми не дуже там складні професії брали да
для таких речей то зрештою дійшли
висновку що симулятори от як з
локомотивом ну ну де Ви де Ви до якого
локомотива ви е-е Якби приведете дітей
чи де ви в якому навчальному закладі
знайдете аж весь перелік всіх ну всіх
цих деревообробних станків я об'їздив ну
половину регіонів України точно був в
закладах професійної освіти от маю вам
сказати що Ну
далеко не всюди де ви заглянете
всередину всередину станка і так далі да
тобто є таке Як раціональна доцільність
тобто
де де краще реально середовище там краще
реальне середовище А де треба
Наочність зобразити якимось іншим чином
ну Відповідно ми запросимо Запрошуємо
таких професіоналів як пан Юрій
останнє запитання від пані Наталії проте
де переглянути симулятор давайте ще раз
і давайте можливо пане Юрію там вже є
курси якісь зокрема
локомотиви вони по-моєму є вже на
основній платформі правда
Давайте давайте тоді здемонстрацію
екрану покроково через браузер про те
заходив на платформу професійна освіта
онлайн дивимось які є професії Заходимо
на професію дивимось в курс і так далі
по кроково зараз відкрию онлайн
це привід зареєструватись на платформі і
однозначно зареєструватись на курси Отже
професій онлайн
Перемога у нас
буквально
з ремонту рухомого складу чи Давайте я
хотів показати мені просто знаєте Не
закритий штальт по електрона цим
освітленням хотів показати і не з них
прокладання
Заходимо в курс то який в мене був
інформація про курс
переглянути курс
Я вже авторизований вам для перегляду
доведеться зареєструватися або увійти
Я входжу
І от закріплення всіх попередньо
вивчених матеріалів практичне вже йде в
технології монтажу от я є вступ до теми
і матеріали теми переходимо зразу в
матеріали там де безпосередньо
розглядається
виконання цих дій от перша етапи монтажу
з яких етапів складається те про що я
говорив це розмітка Пробивні монтажні
монтаж проводки наступним етапом
розмітка мова йде про розмітку і коли
виходимо доходимо до кінця це
інструкційне відео яке вже показував ось
є приклад те що я теж показував
фрагментарно і зараз у нас тут
підвантажується підвантажується
qr-код з завданням
от от тут qr-код завдання зараз має
підвантажити все так само як і в
наступному давайте ще тут подивимося
Пробивні роботи аналогічні
трішки затримка в мене дуже щось
повільну платформа зараз
підвантаження цього об'єкта вимагає
трошки затримка часу
так так так так так так ось воно
ініціалізація пішла бачите Ось пішло і
оце вибачте
Правильно правильно Ну зараз я засвітив
свій qr-код тому всі хто відсканує його
я отримую ваші відсотки Ну просто так не
виконували що Тому Хто захоче від мого
імені пройти можете проходити
можна ось по кліпу
в принципі можна як в режимі як гість
але результати не будуть нікуди
підтягуватися в курс тому якщо ви просто
пройдете за цим посиланням з телефону
свого смартфона Воно вас переадресує
вона автоматично визначить операційну
систему вашого смартфона якщо це Android
ви підете на Play Market якщо це
обсторова вона
якщо цей iPhone то піде на App Store і
звідки запропоную вам встановити
застосовувати
після встановлення перше що у вас
вопроси застосунок це відсканувати цей
qr-код
відсканувавши qr-код ви підв'яжете свій
застосунок до конкретного користувача на
платформі для того щоб результати були
синхронізовані От так це працює
тож я дуже дякую всім хто взяв участь в
сьогоднішньому вебінарі
шановні панове спікери у вас я прошу
залишитись в Зумі для того щоб ми з вами
обмінялись посиланнями на ваші
презентації на матеріали і посібники щоб
могли могли їх залишити в описі до відео
а всім глядачам я Бажаю гарного Тихого
Мирного дня і Приблизно через годинку в
описі до цього відео Чекайте посилання
на посібники всім всього найкращого До
побачення